okay in this video we're gonna talk
about just some basic tips about how to
use the the compass a lot of students
when they start doing these
constructions in their geometry class
they get a little bit frustrated just
not knowing how to work with the compass
and then you know they get discouraged
and whatnot so let me just see if I can
show you so here's a really basic
compass it's just a plastic one there's
some better ones out there but you don't
need a complicated compass the main
thing you want to make sure though is
that these two points come together at
the end you don't want one point down
here and one point up here you want the
two end points to come together that's
the key to having up your constructions
come out you know efficiently and
effectively the other thing you want to
do is when you're using the compass you
want to pivot on this point right here
so you want to hold the compass over
here and on this part of the compass you
don't want to move the pencil you want
to you want to put your pressure on this
point that's your pivot point and that's
what's going to give you a good arc when
you draw it okay the other thing is is
that some students though when they use
a compass they put the pencil
perpendicular to the paper and a lot of
times what happens is it skips along the
paper it like skips and so what you want
to do is just my suggestion is it tilted
it a little bit of an angle like see I'm
tilting you like kind of like a 45
degree angle and then what you can do is
you can pivot okay like this okay or
what you can do is just move the paper
and let the pencil just go ahead and you
know trace the arc like so so just
rotate the paper instead of rotating the
compass